اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعد نرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
وسط مخاوف من توسع اعمال العوم في اسرائيل
هو رغبه الفرنسيه امريكيه في دور صيني في
جهود انهاء الحرب الاوكرانيه
في خطوه جديده ضد المراه الافغانيه حركه
الطالبان تمنع موظفات الامم المتحده من
العمل
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا حاله من التوتر الامني
منذ ليله البارحه تشهدها الاراضي
الفلسطينيه اذ اقتحمت قوات الاسرائيليه
فجر اليوم باحات المسجد الاقصى وهشمت بعضا
واحده ثم القت قنابل صوتيه لاجبار
المحتكفين داخل المسجد على المغادره عمليه
الاقتحام اسفرت حسب هيئه الشؤون الاسرى عن
اعتقال نحو 500 معتكف بينما قالت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه انها اوقفت 350 اليان الاحمر
الفلسطيني اكد وقوع اصابات جراء الاقتحام
معلنا حاله الاستنفار دعوات الاعتكاف في
المسجد الاقصى جاءت لمنع مستوطنين من
جماعات الهيكل كما يسمون من دخول المسجد
خارج القدس مشاهدينا اندلعت اشتباكات بين
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاسرائيليه في عده
مخيمات في نابلس والخليل وطولكرم في الضفه
الغربيه تبعا لذلك حذر الناطق باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل ابو ردينه حذر
اسرائيل من تجاوز الخطوط الحمر في الاماكن
المقدسه والتي من شانها ان تؤدي الى
انفجار كبير على حظ وصفه على حد وصفه
هذا هو اعلنت هيئه الاذاعه الاسرائيلي ان
الجيش قصف صباح اليوم واقع في قطاع غزه
وافاد مراس العربيه بان الغارات استهدفت
موقع بدر العسكري التابع لحماس فيما اعلنت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان القبه الحديديه
اعترضت اربع صواريخ اطلقت من القطاع وقد
جرى تشغيل صفاره الانذار في مستوطنات غلاف
غزه بينها مستوطنه
[موسيقى]
وفي ردود الفعل العربيه اعلنت الخارجيه
السعوديه في بيان انها تتابع بقلق بالغ
عمليه اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لباحات المسجد الاقصى ودانه
هذا الاعتداء الذي وصفته بالسافر وعبرت
ايضا عن رفضها القاطع لهذه الممارسات التي
تقوض جهد السلام الخريه السعوديه مشاهدينا
ايضا جددت في بيانها موقفها الراسخ في دعم
الجهود الراميه الى انهاء الاحتلال
والوصول الى حل شامل وعاد للقضيه
الفلسطينيه من جهتها ادانه الخارجيه
المصريه اقتحام الشرطه الاسرائيليه للمسجد
الاقصى ومصاحب ذلك من اعتداءات ادت الى
وقوع اصابات عديده بين المصلين واعتبرت
مصر ان مثل هذه الاعتداءات تؤجج مشاعر
الغضب لدى جميع ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
والشعب الاسلاميه وطالبت اسرائيل بالوقوف
الفوري لبابل بالوقف الفوري لتلك
الارتداءات وطالبت في بيانها المجتمع
الدولي بالتحمل مسؤوليته في وضع حد لذلك
الاعتداءات وتجنيب المنطقه المزيد من
عوامل عدم الاستقرار والتوتر الخارجي
الاردني ايضا مشاهدينا بدورها نددت بعمليه
اقتحام اسرائيل للمسجد الاقصى ووصفته
بالانتهاك الصارخ
وهذه مشاهدينا الصور مباشره للحرم القسي
حيث يبدو الهدوء يوم المكان عقب التوترات
الامنيه الكبيره منذ ليله البارحه التي
تشهدها الاراضي الفلسطينيه اذ اقتحمت كما
ذكرنا قوات اسرائيليه فجر هذا اليوم حاد
المسجد الاقصى وحشمت بعض النوافذ والقت
ايضا قنابل صوتيه لاجبار المعتكفين داخل
المسجد على المغادره عمليه الاقتحام هذه
مشاهدينا بحسب هيئه شؤون الاسرى
يعني تسببت في اعتقال نحو 500 معتكف بين
مقاله الشرطه الاسرائيليه انها اوقفت 300
شخصا
مشاهدينا الان تنضم الينا من القدس مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك لانها كما نتابع في هذه
الصور لنا الوضع يبدو هادئا تماما امام او
في بحاد المسجد الاقصى هل هو هدوء ما قبل
العاصفه من الاوضاع ستستمر في هذا الوضع
بحسب الاجراءات الامنيه المتخذه من قبل
الاسرائيليين لنا
اهلا بك احمد صحيح يعني منذ ساعات الصباح
الباكر في تمام الساعه السابعه في توقيت
القدس كان هناك اقتحام من قبل مجموعتين من
المستوطنين وايضا اليهود قاموا باقتحام
الساحات المسجد الاقصى بحمايه اعداد كبيره
من القوات الاسرائيليه ولكن الان كان هناك
يعني هدوء دعنا نصفه بانه هدوء يعني حذر
فعليا داخل ساحات المسجد الاقصى بعد
اقتحام اعداد كبيره ايضا من اليهود ساحات
المسجد الاقصى قاموا بالدخول من باب
المغاربه
والتجول في ساحات المسجد الاقصى وخروجا من
باب السلسله في ظل هذه
الاجواء كان هناك ايضا تواجد لعدد من
الفلسطينيين داخل المسجد الاقصى يحاولون
يعني الصد لهذه الاقتحامات ولكن القوات
الاسرائيليه قامت باعتقال ايضا عدد منهم
صباح اليوم واخ عدد اخر من الفلسطينيين من
من ساحات المسجد الاقصى كان هناك ايضا
اعتداء على سيده فلسطينيه من داخل المسجد
الاقصى دعنا نصف بان هذا التوتر مازال
موجودا وهناك حاله تاهب ايضا في البلده
القديمه في القدس وانتشار كبير للقوات
الاسرائيليه يعني تاهبا لزياد التوتر
فعليا بعد ان شاهدنا عشر ايام هادئه من
رمضان في القدس والمسجد الاقصى المبارك
طيب لنا من نشاهدهم في هذه الصور انهم
فلسطينيون اليس كذلك يعني هل سمحت سلطه
الاسرائيليه للفلسطينيين بالعوده الى
زياره المسجد الاقصى بشكل طبيعي
عفوا هل سمحت لهم ماذا يعني نشاهد في
الصور على ما يبدو انه فلسطينيون في هذه
الصور
زوار للمسجد الاقصى هل يعني ذلك ان
السلطات الاسرائيليه سمحت لبعضهم بالعوده
للصلاه وزياره المسجد الاقصى والحرم
القدسي بعد هذه العمليه التي اجاره الصباح
اليوم
صحيح كان هناك عوده كالمعتاد للصلاه من
قبل الفلسطينيين
والمقدسيين للصلاه في المسجد الاقصى بعد
ان قامت ايضا باعتقال اكثر من 400 فلسطيني
ليله امس وقامت ايضا باخراج عدد منهم ولكن
اعداد كبيره تم اخراجهم بشروط الابعاد
لاسابيع او اسبوع على الاقل من البلده
القديمه او حتى منع الدخول للمسجد الاقصى
وايضا غرامات ماليه ايضا قبل قليل كان
هناك اعتقال لاحد المستوطنين او ايقاف
فعليا حاول الدخول الى البلده القديمه
وكان يحمل القرابين وكان هناك ايضا محاوله
ودعوات من قبل المستوطنين بوجود مكافات
لمن يستطيع الدخول الى المسجد الاقصى وذبح
ما يعرف بالقرابين اليهوديه بسبب الاعياد
اليهوديه هل من دعوات الاحتجاج والتصعيد
رصدت في المناطق الفلسطينيه او في القدس
تحديدا
ضد حدث خلال صباح هذا اليوم لنا
صحيح هناك دعوات حتى من الداخل الفلسطيني
واراضي ال 48 هناك دعوات كبيره من
الفلسطينيين للذهاب الى المسجد الاقصى
والاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى ردا على
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه هناك ايضا دعوات
لاحتجاجات وايضا الاشتباك مع القوات
الاسرائيليه على اعداد كبيره من الحواجز
كان هناك ايضا قبل قليل اطلاق النار على
احد الحواجز الاسرائيليه في مدينه بيت لحم
التي تفصل بين الضفه الغربيه واراضي 48
والقدس نحن نتحدث عن يعني بدء حاله التوتر
بشكل كبير وهناك يعني احتمال كبير بان
تتفجر الاوضاع وتخرج عن السيطره خاصه بان
ايضا هناك دعوات منه وزير الامن القومي
اعتمر بن جفير بالذهاب
وذهاب المستوطنين واقتحامهم للمسجد الاقصى
وهناك ايضا مطالبات من بنك فير بالرد بشكل
كبير على الفصائل الفلسطينيه في قط اع غزه
وايضا يقول بان اطلاق الصواريخ في مناطق
مفتوحه ضد فصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
هو امر غير كافي ويجب الرد بشكل قاسي على
هذه الفصائل في القطاع
بهذا القدر مع كلانا ولكم معك في متابعه
دائمه لمجريات هذا اليوم ونذكر مشاهدين
ايضا بان هذه الصور المباشره لبائحه
الاخصاب عقب عمليه الاقتحام التي جرت صباح
اليوم من السلطاتها الاسرائيليه شكرا لك
قال الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق دونالد ترامب
في كلمته الاولى من ماراولاجو بعد مثوله
امام المحكمه بمنحاه قال ان الديمقراطيين
هاجموه بشكل شخصي وحاول نيل منه بتحقيقات
الزائفه لا اساس لها من الصحه طلب
مشاهدينا اضاف انه لم يكن يتوقع ان يمثل
بهذه الطريقه امام المحكمه وان القضيه
التي رفعت ضده هدفها التاثير على انتخابات
2024 مؤكدا على الضروره اسقاطها فورا طلب
مشاهدينا اشار في كلمته الى عدم الوثوق
بالادله التي قدموها ضده في المحكمه لافته
لان نظام قضائي الامريكي فقد قانونيته
نتابعه
هذه حمله موجهه شخصيا ضدي وليست تحقيقا
المدعي العام الفاشل يوجه اتهامات ضد رئيس
امريكي السابق امر يحصل لاول مره في
التاريخ ويستخدم في ذلك ادله غير قانونيه
لا توجد هنا قضيه قانونيه ضدي القضيه
باطله لا يمكن الوثوق بالادله التي قدموها
ضد في المحكمه والمجرم الحقيقي هنا هو
مدعي عامه
الذي يجب مقاضاته وعليه تقديم استقالته
فورا
القضيه المرفوعه ضد هدفها التاثير على
انتخابات 2004
عرضنا طواعيه على مكتب التحقيقات الاطلاع
على الوثائق السريه التي كانت في منزلي في
مرالاجو واستعادتها هذه الوثائق كانت
بحوزه بشكل قانوني احضرتها خلال فتره
كرئيس وبعلم الجميع وهذا امر فعله كل رئيس
امريكي سبقني وكنت اتعامل بحسن نيه الى ان
هاجم الاف بي اي منزلي هذا يبرهن ان
النظام القضائي الامريكي فقد قانونيته
وانهم يحاولون سرقه الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
لم اعتقد ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث
في الولايات المتحده جريمه الوحيده هي
الدفاع عن البلاد ضد من يحاول تدميرها كما
تذكرون الديمقراطيون تجسسوا على حمله
الانتخابيه منذ البدايه وحاولوا النيل مني
بتحقيقات زائفه لا اساس لها من الصحه
وهاجموني بشكل شخصي
في اول رد فعل دوري وصفت الخارجيه الروسيه
مشهد محاكمه الرئيس الامريكي الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب بانه دليل على ازمه
ليبراليه في امريكا وازدواجيه المعايير
وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره ماريا
زهاروفا ان ترامب ملاحق قضائيا بسبب طموحه
في العوده الى الرئاسه والخلل في تطبيق
الايديولوجيا الليبراليه ومافاهيم
الديمقراطيه
مشاهدينا واشنطن المحلل السياسي ايهاب
عباس اهلا بك في هذه النشره كما تابعنا
ترامب فتح النار الجميع النظام القضائي في
البلاد مدعي عام وديمقراطيين كذلك هل هي
الطريقه الامثل من قبل الرئيس الامريكي
السابق للتعاطي معهد الازمه
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بكل المشاهدين لو كان
هناك من يتوقع الا يقوم ترامب بما قام به
بعد جلسه المحاكمه فهو مخطئ بكل تاكيد
يعني قام بما هو كان متوقعا منه من قبل
انصاره ومحبيه ومؤيديه وكل من يشعر ان
الولايات المتحده تسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ
بسبب سياسات الديمقراطيه التي تمارس من
قبل اداره جو بايدن خلال الفتره الماضيه
صحيح انه هجم بشده مدعي عام من هاته وكذلك
حتى القاضي اخوان مارشن هاجمه بشكل غير
مباشر
واتهم ان ابنته لديها علاقات شخصيه مع
نائبه الرئيس كماله هاريس وانها من
المستفيدين في هذا الاطار واتهم عنتر
بايدن وفتح النيران على الديمقراطيين بشكل
عام
واكد انه سيحاول ان يستعيد امريكا من جديد
وطبعا
كل افكاره التي يعتقدها فيما يتعلق بحكم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا ما جاء
رئيسا للبلاد وانه سيقضي على كل هذه
المشكلات التي يتسبب فيها الديمقراطيون
وتحديدا اليسار التقدمي في الحزب
الديمقراطي وهذا ايضا على انه حقق المزيد
من المكاسب من هذه الازمه خاصه على صعيد
شعبيته والدعم الكبير الذي حظيت به الحمله
الانتخابيه بالنسبه له صحيح هذا الطرح نعم
صحيح في اقل من 24 ساعه حمله دونالد ترامب
جامعه خمسه ملايين دولار وكانت قد جمعت
خمسه ملايين دولار اخرى في حوالي عشره
ايام فهذا هذا يدل على ان المواطنين
الامريكيين تحديدا الطبقات المتوسطه
وطبقات العامله والكادحه ترى في هذا الرجل
هو النصير الحقيقي للشعب الامريكي والذي
يستطيع ان يقف في وجه الديمقراطيه
الليبراليه التي لم تحقق شيء على مدار
عامين للمواطنين يبدو ان السيليتو
الجمهوريه كان له راي اخر فهو قد هاجمت
بشده واعتبر انه لم يعد مناسبا المنصب
رئيس الولايات المتحده هل يغرد مترو خارج
السرب ام انه يمثل التيار عريضا داخل
الحزب الحزب الجمهوري في
هو يغرد خارج السرب هو بعض الجمهوريين لكن
ليسوا هم المين ستريم او التيار الرئيسي
داخل الحزب الجمهوري في الوقت الحالي
شاهدنا ان حتى
الشخصيات الجمهوريه التي
نتحدث عنها اليوم انها ربما تكون مرشحه
امام الرئيس
الانتخابات التمهيديه داخل حزب الجمهوري
تمهيدا للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه هذه
الشخصيات حتى تقف بجوار دانالد ترامب
نتحدث عن المنافس الرئيسي له
[موسيقى]
الذي اكد انه يقف بجانب ترامب وانما يحدث
مع ترامب لا يجوز انها مطارده سياسيه
للرجل كذلك نكهه هيلي حكمت
ساسكا رولاينا
ومندوبه الولايات المتحده السابقه في
الامم الم تحدثت عن نفس الامر نائبه
السابق والذي بينهما خلافات حتى اليوم
ويقال انه ربما يكون احد المرشحين عن
الحزب الخوض للانتخابات الرئاسيه يقف ايضا
بجانب الرئيس
دونالد ترامب كل الاعضاء الكبار تقريبا في
الحزب الجمهوري والقيادات المتوسطه على
مستوى الحزب تقف بجانب الرجل من يغرد خارج
الحزب يعني خرز الشرب معروفون لدى
الجمهورين واصبحوا منبوذين حتى على
السياسي نعم شكرا لك من واشنطن على المحلل
السياسي ايهاب عبر استحيته تحياتي شكرا
جزيلا نشطنا مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد
الفاصل اعلام روسي يتحدث عن تحطم طائره
مسيره بولنديه الصنع قربه محطه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد وصل الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل في زياره الى الصين
ترافق فيها رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبي ارسل
كما يرافقه عدد كبير من الوزراء ورجال
الاعمال ورؤساء الشركات الذين سيوقع بعضهم
بعضهم عقودا مع شركات صينيه وستكون الحرب
في اوكرانيا في صلب المحادثات التي سيجيها
ماكرون عن المسؤولين الصينيين واعلن
اليزيا بعد اتصال هاتفي بين الرئيسين
الفرنسي والامريكي الليله الماضيه ان
بايدن عرب عن رغبتهم المشتركه في اشراك
الصين في جهود تسريع انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
وهذه الصور
كنا نتابع سنه معكم صوره مباشره للرئيس
الفرنسي لكن ربما نعود اليها في سياق هذه
النشره عند مشاهدينا الان ينضم الينا من
بكين الصحفي نادي نادر معنا في هذه النشره
بدايه هذه الزياره زياره الرئيس الفرنسي
الى الصين البدعوه من الرئيس الصيني ما
الذي ترغب بكين في تحقيقه من هذه الزياره
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذه زياره تحميل واحميه
كبرى للتدوير العلاقات بين الصين وفرنسا
وبين الصين واوروبا كذلك
من خلال هذه الزيارات سيلتقي الرئيس
الفرنسي
مع رئيس الفرنسي وكذلك كبار مسؤولين في
الصين
ويعني يرسموا مستقبل التطور العلاقات بين
البلدين وكذلك العمل على تعميق التعاون في
مختلف المجالات بين الصين وفرنسا وتراسين
ان هذه
الزياره او هذا
التعميق التعاون سيسب لصالح البلدين وكذلك
سيساهم في السلام والاستحار في العالم طيب
سيدنا نحن الان نتابع في القسم الاخر من
الشاشه هذه الصور المباشره
من داخل الس الفرنسيه في بكيل وننتظر كلمه
سيقيها الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
بعد قليل على ضوء هذه الزياره التي اجراها
الى بكين زياره تدوم الى ثلاثه ايام في
مهمه وساطه ايضا كما قالت كثير من المصادر
من البلدين في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه
وايضا يرافق الرئيس الفرنسي عدد من
الوزراء ورجال الاعمال ورؤساء الشركات كما
ذكرنا والذين سيوقع بعضهم عقودا مع شركات
صينيه طيب السيد نادر تحدثنا عن مدى اهميه
هذه الزياره لكن ماذا عن موضوع الوساطه
فيما يتعلق بالحرب الصينيه عفوا الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه الى اي مدى يشكل هذا
الملف اولويه في هذه الزياره بنسبه
للطرفين
اه طبعا بالاضافه الى التعاون الاقتصادي
والتبادل الثقافي للتنسيق مواقف في حول
القضايا الدولي الخامه الساخنه ايضا
ملف هذه الزياره الصين اكدت انها تدعم
جميع الجهود الراميه الى ايجار حل سلمي
لازمه في اوكرانيا وكذلك الصين ايضا تامل
ان تتبادل الاراء مع الجنب الفرنسي وكذلك
الجانب الاوروبي حول
ايجاد حل السلمي لهذه الازمه
كذلك تامل من القاره الاوروبيه الاتخاذ
قراراتها بشكل مستقل وكذلك
تعمل مع الصين لايجاد حال سلمي لهذه
طيب شكرا جزيلا لك من بكين كنت معنا
الصحفي النادي الرونك تحياتي السيد نادر
شكرا شكرا وصل رئيس الاوكراني
رسميه حيث سيلتقي في وارسو نظيره البولندي
وكانت الرئاسه البولندي اعلنت مؤخرا تسليم
اوكرانيا عدد من مقاتلات 29 لاول مره فضلا
عن دبابات الالمانيه او الالمانيه
الى الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت مسيره هولنديه
النوويه وذكرت التقارير الروسيه ان
المسيره تزن كيلوغرامين وتم اسقاطها قرب
المحطه النوويه جاء ذلك بينما من المتوقع
ان يزور مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه
حيث يجري محادثات بشان سبل حمايه المحطه
النوويه من الاعمال القتاليه
[موسيقى]
بل جبهه شماليه لحلف النيتو وجبهه اقوى
لتتشارك روسيا الان
2600 كلم مع اربع من دول الحلف
قوه اضافيه كسبها الحلف فبالرغم من حيادها
لم تخفض فنلندا ميزانيه الدفاع منذ الحرب
البارده ليتحول بحر البلطيق الى منطقه
نفود للنيتو بانتظار انضمام السويد التي
تواجه مشكله مع تركيا خطوه ستزيد من عدد
قوات الحلف المنتشره شرق اوروبا تحديدا
على الحدود المشتركه مع روسيا الى ما
يقارب 300 الف جندي ما قد تراه موسكو
التصعيدا يدفعها الى فعل مماثل بعسكره
حدودها وهو ما بدا جليا في تصريحات الكريم
يرى الكرملين ان ذلك تفاقم اخر للوضع
وانها توسع النيتو تعد على امننا ومصالح
روسيا الاتحاديه ننظر الى ذلك بهذه
الطريقه بالضبط وسنتخذ تدابير مضاده لضمان
امننا التكتيكي والاستراتيجي باب يتركه
حلف النيتو مفتوحا رغم التهديدات الروسيه
لتمر عبره السويد قريبا وربما اوكرانيا
لاحقا ما قد يفجر غضبا روسيا من نوع جديد
او يضع حدا لطموح موسكو التوسعي الى عمر
العربيه
استانفت اليوم بل استانفت اليوم الرحلات
الجويه بين اربيل وجده حيث اقلعت اول
طائره من مطار اربيل الدولي الى مدينه جده
السعوديه عبر الناقل الجوي السعوديه
الرحله نقلت على متنها
172 مسافرا بين معتمر وسائح ومن متوقع ان
يكون جدول الرحلات مسجلا بواقع رحلتين
اسبوعيا بين مطار اربيل وجده كمرحله
الاولى
بعد مرور نحو شهرين من وقوع زلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا لا تزال المساعده التي
تقدمها السعوديه المتضرر زلزال تتدفق الى
هذه المناطق اخرها اعلان مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه توزيع ثلاثه
واربعين طنا من السلع الغذائيه لمتضرري
زلزال في محافظه ادلب شمال سوريا حيث اوضح
المركز ان نحو 400 اسره استفادت منها في
مدينتي ادلب وحارم مضيفا ان هذه المساعدات
تاتي امتداد للجهود الاغاثيه والانسانيه
التي تقدمها السعوديه عبر المركز لاغاثه
الدول المتضرره في مختلف الازمات
نشاطنا مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
اعلام ايراني يتحدث عن احباط هجوم بطائره
مسيره على مجمع وزاره دفاعي في اصفهان
[موسيقى]
وسطها مخاوف من توسع الاعمال العنف في
اسرائيل تقتحم باحات الاقصى وتبادل
النيران عبر حدود غزه
تصف محاكمته بازدواجيه المعايير الامريكيه
ورغبه الفرنسيه امريكيه في دور صيني في
جهود انهاء الحرب الاوكرانيه
في خطوه جديده ضد المراه الافغانيه حركه
طالبان تمنع موظفات الامم المتحده من
العمل
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد ذكرت وكاله
التسليم الايرانيه ان مجمع وزاره الدفاع
في اصفهان تعرض لهجوم بطائره مسيره واضافت
ان انظمه الدفاع اسقطه الطائره المسيره
لدى اقترابها من مجمع وزاره الدفاع في
اصفهان الليله الماضيه واشارت الى عدم
وقوع اضرار
في السودان مشاهدينا اعلنت القوى المدنيه
الواقعه الاتفاق الاطري في بيان عقب
اجتماعها لمناقشه تطورات السياسيه عن
استلامها نسخه مسوده الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي التي اعدتها لجنه الصياغه بمشاركه
جميع اعضائها العسكريين والمدنيين مخدعه
المسوده للدراسه والنقاش لتصبح جاهزه فيما
عدا القضايا الفنيه المتبقيه في ملف
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري والتي اكد
المجتمعون انها تشهد تقدما ملموسا داخل
اللجان الفنيه المعنيه مع ضروره مضاعفه
الجهد من اجل تجاوز العقبات المتبقيه
واكدت القوانيتها الترتيب الاجتماعي عاجل
للقوى العسكريه والمدنيه الموقعه الاتفاق
الايطالي بهدف بحث العقبات المتبقيه مما
يساهم في توقيع الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
باعجال ما تيسر
في خطوه جديده اتخذتها حركه طالبان ضد عمل
للمراه الافغانيه قال مسؤولون في الامم
المتحده ان سلطات طالبان في شرق افغانستان
منعت الموظفات الافغانيات في الامم
المتحده من العمل كما عرضت باحثه الامم
المتحده عن قلق بالغ بعد منع موظفاتها من
الذهاب الى العمل بولايه نانجرهار وقالت
بعثه الامم المتحده ان على السلطه هناك ان
تعلم ان كيانات الامم المتحده لا يمكن لها
ان تعمل وتوصي المساعدات التي تنقذ الحياه
دون موظفاتها
فقد الملياردير الامريكي الى ماسك لقب
اغنى شخص في العالم لصالح رجل الاعمال
الفرنسي برنار ارنو وهو مؤسسه والرئيس
التنفيذي لمجموعه لويس التي تتكون من 70
ماركه من الماركات والعلامات التجاريه
العالميه وذلك بعد ان تراجع ماسك المركز
الثاني بعد خسارته تسعه وثلاثين مليار
دولار من صافي ثروته خلال العام الماضي
واوضحت مجله فورس ان استحواذ ماسك على
تويتر قد ادى الى انخفاض قيمه اسهم شركه
تسلا بنحو 50%
في قرار مفاجئ قام بالاعضار الامريكي
بتغيير شعار تويتر من الطائر الازرق الى
شعار عمله دوك كوين الافتراضيه ويعتبر
ماسك من ابوظ الداعمين لهذه العمله
الافتراضيه وكان سمح بدفع قيمه السيارات
تسلا بهذه العمله نتابع
اصبح كلبا بقوه قانون ايلون ماسك
الملياردير الاميركي يقول انه غير شعار
منصه تويتر ولا تعرف بعد جديه ماسك من
مسحه الا ان البعض كشف انها دعايه من ماسك
لعمله دوك وين المشفره التي يتبناها
ماسك نشر تغريده مقتضبه على صفحته الرسميه
على تويتر قال فيها كما وعدت ارفق بها
صوره من تغريدات متبادله بينه وبين احد
المستخدمين الاخرين الذي طلب منه تغيير
شعار تويتر المعروف بالطائر الازرق الى
عمله دوكين
وسابقا سمح بدفع قيمه سيارات تسلا
الكهربائيه بهذه العملات الافتراضيه اذ
تبناها بعد ان قرر الابتعاد عن بيتكوين
وغرد عنها عده مرات من قبل
خطوه ماسك ادت الى صعود قيمه الى ما يصل
الى 10.2 سنت من حوالي سبعه فاصله سبعه اي
بنسبه تصل الى 30% وتعد هذه العمله
الثامنه اكثر العملات المشفره قيمه حيث
تبلغ قيمتها السوقيه اكثر من 13 مليار
دولار
خطوه ماسك تاتي بعد تغييرات كثيره احدثها
على منصه تويتر التي ظلت هادئه الى ان
سيطر عليها بلال البجداني العربيه
في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه فرنسا الخميس
ليوم تحرك النقابي وشعبي جديد واسع النطاق
ضد رفع سن التقاعد تستقبض رئيسه الوظائف
الفرنسيه اليوم الاربعاء ممثلين
كما ستواصل استقبال ممثلين عن احزاب
سياسيه للتشاور معهم هذا وقد اعلنت
الامينه العامه الجديده للكونفدراليه
العامه للعمل ان اللقاء مع بون سيكون
قصيرا جدا اذا لم تعلن استعدادها خلاله
لسحب قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد المتنازع
عليه مشيره الى انه في حال انتهى اللقاء
دون اتفاق فان ذلك سينعكس على اعداد
المشاركين في التحرك غدا الخميس
مشاهدينا يشهد المسجد الحرام عمليه تنظيم
دقيقه ل 100,000 المعتمرين والمصلين
والزائرين في شهر رمضان
[موسيقى]
في بيروت تحاول دار الايتام الاسلاميه
اطفاء البهجه على ايتاء على ايام الصوم
رغم الازمه الاقتصاديه ونظام ككل عام جوله
في شوارع بيروت لاطفال الدار غنوا خلالها
اغنيات حفظها اللبنانيون عن ظهر قلب
وحاولت الدهر تزيين الشوارع بما تيسر
لاستقبال الشهر الفضيل
[موسيقى]
رغم كل الازمات لا يتاخروا اطفال دار
الايتام الاسلاميه عن استقبال شهر الصوم
المبارك
بفرحهم جالوا على الشوارع بيروت وزقتها
مرددين اغنيات باتت جزءا لا يتجزا من ارث
رمضان
على جانبي الطرقات اصطفى المواطنون
لملاقاه مواكب الفرح التي انطلقت هذا
العام تحت عنوان دار الخير داركم
بنصلي وبنصبح ربنا
والجوله اللي عملناها عملناها كرمال نذكر
العالم برمضان ونفرحهم رمضان شهر الخير
شهر بركه شهر الغفار شهر الغفران شعر
الرحمن
بدي احكي لك عن رمضان بنتسحر بنروح على
يلي القدر بنصلي صلاه التراويح
اتخذت دار الايتام الاسلاميه على عاتقها
اضاءه شمعه وسط الظلم ومع غياب الزينه عن
بيروت اختارت ثلاثه شوارع رئيسيه فقط
لتزيينها مع وقوف الازمه الاقتصاديه عائقا
امام تزيين كامل العاصمه ولم تستخدم الدار
زينه جديده بل اصلحت القديم كي لا تغيب
الاجواء الرمضانيه عن اللبنانيين خففنا
يعني بدك تقولي لحدود 15% من كنا نصرفه
على موازنه الزينه وكل صار شغل داخلي يعني
هذه الزينه منخزنها عنا بالمستودعات فنحن
الفنيين اللي عنا اشتغلوا فيها غيرنا
اللمبات واهلناها بنتكل عم نتعهد بس يلي
بع لقها على الاعمده يعني فبدك تقولي بين
10 و15% ماكسيموم من اللي كنا ندفعه على
مصاريف الزين الرمضانيه ببيروت وبالمناطق
داروا الخيريه داركم هذا هو الشعار الذي
اختارته الدار لتؤكد خلال رمضان ان
ابوابها ستبقى مفتوحه لكل محتاج غنوه يتيم
العربيه بيروت
ولا مشاهدينا بقي ان نذكر بابرز العناوين
[تصفيق]
وسط مخاوف فمن توسع اعمال العنف في
اسرائيل تقتحم مباحات الاقصى وتتبادر
النيران عبر حدود غزه
الرئيس السابق ترامب يدفع ببراءته وروسيا
تصف محاكمته بازدواجيه المعايير الامريكيه
ماكرون ورغبه فرنسي امريكيه في دوري صيني
في جهود انهاء الحرب الاوكرانيه
وفي خطوه جديده ضد المراه الافغانيه حركه
طالبان تمنع موظفات الامم المتحده من
العمل
هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]